- This is really a risky thing
I've wanted to do all my
life and I finally did it.
- [Kelly] What?
- So, as you mentioned, I
just released my 65th album.
- Yeah that's, congratulations!
That's so cool!
- Thank you, it's so, I mean
(applause)
so it's about a fifteen
minute improv section
where I put all 65 albums on
the huge screens behind me,
and I turn to the audience and say,
'Okay, the show is yours.'
I have no idea what's going to happen,
it's all improv, you can pick any song
from any album that I've ever done
in my entire life, and
we're gonna do it for you.
- [Kelly] What?
- [Donny] It is, it's my
favorite part of the show.
- Wait, I'm stressed thinking about it.
- [Donny] Oh it's so fun!
- That's cool though that it's improv
and they get, because most shows
you know, you go see a show, like a tour
that's the same show every night
- [Donny] Yeah.
- So that's cool, it's different.
- [Donny] My show is
different every night.
- Oh that's so cool!
- [Woman Guest] Fun!
- I love that!
- Do they ever ask for One Bad Apple?
- [Donny] We do One Bad Apple.
- Oh good!
I love that song!
(Kelly laughing)
- Except we, what we do is we,
- That's with all the brothers.
- Oh, that was some of
our first number one,
- I know.
- In fact, Michael told
me that, allegedly,
it was written for the J Five, and I said,
'well I got one on you Mike,'
Ben, his number one solo Ben,
- [Woman Guest] Yeah?
- Was written for me.
- [Woman Guest] Whoa!
- Oh my god, really?
- [Donny] That was my song.
- [Woman Guest] What happened?
- Well I was on,
- That was on that creepy movie.
- It was about a rat or some Willard?
- Yes, about rats.
Willard, Willard!
- Which I always though was interesting,
Michael sang about a rat,
I sang about a puppy.
(guest and Kelly laughing)
- Fascination with animals.
(Donny laughing)
- [Donny] Exactly!
- It's fine.
- But I said, 'yeah Ben
was written for me.'
The reason I didn't record Ben was
I was on the road,
touring with my brothers,
and they had to finish the movie,
and the producer said, 'well,
there is this little kid
named Michael Jackson,
let's get him to sing.
He's got a high voice.'
And it became his song.
It's so funny,
- [Kelly] That's so funny
how songs find their homes.
- Yeah, they find their homes,
and Mike and I would laugh
about it all the time.
- Oh my gosh!
That's so, your life was so crazy cool!
- [Donny] It was crazy.